we want to take your land nicely we want
to kick you out nicely we want to seize
this and make this state exclusive for
us we want to do it nicely and we're
offering you a chance give us your home
or we will kill you what a Wonderful
Merciful offer that was Eddie and then
the Arabs decided to invade when the
zionists go out and kick out the
Palestinians from their home when the
zionists Go and Kill the Palestinians
when they Turf them from their land
something that is illegal under every
legal code on this Earth even here in
the United States of America America if
someone enters your land without
permission and refuses to leave what do
you do Eddie you you're allowed legally
to shoot him I mean under every legal
code this is absolutely outrageous